[Music]
hello and welcome to windzone focus I'm
deina William this week on the program
kiwi Ian momack shares his story of
survival after being left for dead on a
remote beach in the Indian
Ocean and we hear from a Middle East
specialist about the increasing number
number of violent attacks against
Christians despite any hopes of the
so-called Arab Spring easing religious
tension across the Middle East the last
two years have brought the highest
reported number of attacks against
Christians according to several
International organizations which
publish watch lists of countries where
discrimination takes place but
journalist Raymond Ibrahim says that
despite the reported upsurge in violence
widespread anti-christian sentiment is
is not new but has historical basis as
he explained to alen Lee if you study
history as I have that's my original you
know focus and discipline of study and I
mean the primary historical sources
there are the same things that you'll
see happening today but there was a
little Gap because there was an
aberration historically which I call and
others call the golden age for
Christians and this occurred during the
colonial era and even a little bit in
the postcolonial era I I just I
basically I say between 1850 to 1950
because the Western Powers became so
dominant over the Islamic world so many
Muslims westernized just because as
Osama Bin Laden uh correctly said people
by Nature favor the strong horse and the
natural byproduct of that is of course
life became pretty good for Christians
because they were no longer really uh
ostracized from their faith and so this
really went on until I according this is
my thesis and and and my theory until
basically the 60s and 70s and now as the
west liberalized and became decadent and
morally lenti and apologetic about
itself and hating its own Christian
Heritage and its own history all of
those things far from attracting Muslims
like the you know as earlier when the
West Was dominant actually repulsed
Muslims and caused them to go back to
their way and so what we're seeing right
now uh especially the the persecution of
Christians is just a it's a continuation
of what happened yesterday and now we're
in that age of where Muslims have
contempt for Western culture and so of
course the natural repercussions and
consequences are things like terrorism
against infidels which of course also
have a historical lineage attacks on
Christians and any number of things
we've seen the the Arab Spring um over
the last the last couple of years and
we've seen leaderships across the Middle
East topple people like Kel Gaddafi you
know often these are the these are
people who are
dictators um that that can't be bad to
lose people like that can
it well it's again it's interesting what
that you say and and and you're
absolutely right because there's a
correlation between dictatorship and
islamist jihadis Sharia and all that but
again I think it's presented in the
wrong way I think the mainstream
narrative is that there's these
dictators and because we're Western
societies we know dictators are bad we
think democracies are great we think
that that's why there's violence and
frustration and Chaos it's because
there's a dictator so the people are
frustrated they're oppressed they wish
to break you know free themselves from
the Yoke of this dictator but if you
really study the history of the Islamic
world you're going to find that
dictators do not create these societies
but rather these societies create
dictators so let's look at Iraq Saddam
husin you know he was of course in the
media portrayed as a terrible human
being and of course he did commit any
number of atrocities but once you took
him out of the picture what happened in
Iraq it's not like all of a sudden
people became happy liberal secular and
and learned to get along what happened
is a humongous Civil War everyone just
attacked everyone sunnis and Shia and
Kurds fighting each other with of course
Christians right in the middle being the
first targets uh you know on the topic
of Christian persecution in just the
last 10 years since the uh Iraq war more
than half of the indigenous population's
either gone or dead because they were
immediately attacked once Saddam was
taken out of the picture so you find
that when you get rid of these guys it's
just total chaos because all these
groups just go right at each other
because each one doesn't want democracy
each one of these groups wants to be the
dominant one and that's why in the end
you do get a dictator and if anything he
tries to keep a lid on this and this is
what Assad is doing this must have
happened relatively recently I I was
working in the in the Middle East 20 OD
years ago and I was working with with
Palestinian Christians and Palestinian
Muslim Muslims and they seemed to get
along fine there was no there was no
sense of animosity at all so so has it
changed marketly in the last 15 20 years
oh it has definitely changed every every
decade like I pointed out my family came
from Egypt they're you know Christian
cops when they were young let's say in
the 40s and the 50s they didn't know
about any of this they didn't see it it
wasn't really happening because again
that is that golden age that's the last
end of the golden age where there was
just no people didn't really you know
pinpoint them out oh you're Christians
this and that because Muslims themselves
were pretty liberalized and then decade
after decade it just got worse so in the
70s it became a lot worse and this is of
course 70s you have the Islamic
revolution in Iran and Etc 80s got worse
90s worse and now it's really it's just
right now in the Islamic world there's
areas especially where there's a big
Christian population that are just
completely under attack and Nigeria
comes to my mind where you know a Sunday
doesn't pass with without an attack on a
church at least one and and dead
Christians it's hard for Christians
isn't it because we are told to turn the
other cheek our our way is is the way of
peace and so that that would put us
really on the back foot wouldn't it yeah
exactly and not only that though I think
it confuses so many Western people even
non you know non-christians but if you
live in the west and there's this sort
of Christian Heritage this kind of
Christian epist ology background and in
your mind you know religion is
Christianity and and Christianity is a
spiritual thing it's separates between
State and church uh you know it doesn't
really have any laws about what to do
other than just like you said turn the
other cheek try to forgive be tolerant
so I think that's one of the biggest
pitfalls is a lot of westerners project
those views onto Muslims and of course
this is a very secular worldview that
does not take into account the singular
differences of of religion so you know
these very antithetical teachings are
obviously having ramifications and
Echoes down the centuries I saw an
article you wrote in which you said that
the the persecution of Christians was um
the the Achilles heel of Islam what did
you mean by that what I mean by that is
it's the it's the Achilles heel or the
ultimate weakness for Islam's image in
the west and the reason I say that is
because um Islamic viol
uh directed towards let's say Israel or
the West will always be articulated
easily by the mainstream media as a
product of grievance they're oppressed
or ostracized and this is just you know
they're frustrated so that's why they're
lashing out but then when you come to
this issue of Christian persecution
under Islam this this justification or
rationalization no longer works because
now Muslims are in the majority it's
their countries where where they make
the majorities you have Islamic
government
and you know then you have Christian
population sometimes they're as little
as 1% and all they want to do is go to
church they have no political influence
or disenfranchised or ostracize or
second class citizens and they just want
to go to church and then the church gets
bombed or they get attacked and beat and
their women get abducted and raped and
forced to convert to Islam etc etc so
that narrative it's I don't think the
mainstream media has a way to justify
because now Muslims are attacking people
who are weak than them who are of the
same often race the same ethnicity the
same names the same backgrounds there's
no political territorial dispute the
hostility is first and foremost a
product of religious
intolerance I mean most people forget
that what we call the Islamic world in
the 7th Century most of that territory
was part of the Christian world and that
in the 7th Century half of the entire
world's Christian population lived in
those in what we call the Arab world
specifically from Morocco to Egypt Syria
Iraq turkey of course uh these were all
Christian regions as I wrote for that
one article uh about all over around the
Islamic World Christians are fleeing and
even that has a historical parallel
because there were a lot of those
Christians who converted then there were
a few who M maintain their religious
identities and became what's called a
VII like a third class citizen who
accepts it just so he can maintain his
religion and then a lot of them fled and
that's exactly what's happening right
now right it's been fascinating to talk
to you today thank you very much indeed
for your time Middle East journalist
Raymond Ibrahim talking there with Alan
Lee still to come from Death to life the
extraordinary story of Ian McCormick is
next and that he does healing Miracles
now
[Music]
today